whoa
guys how you doing so they just
announced a whole bunch of crazy stuff
about
star wars um at this disney investor day
event that they're having
first thing we've got to talk about the
socatano spin-off series live action
undoubtedly happening now kathleen
kennedy setter herself
and rangers of the new republic which
mandalorian recently tweeted out john
you want to read what it says
they say rangers of the new republic a
new original series set within the
timeline of the mandalorian is coming to
disney plus along with apparently 10
other star wars related series in the
next several years
and i'm thinking to myself that perhaps
that whole thing that we had going with
cara dune that we've been showing with
her being part of the new republic
maybe car this will be like part of her
little show but they don't want to spoil
mandalorian season 2 for us yet so
they're not saying much
right now they are airing an early look
at the obi-wan
series and here's what they said there
that was like whoa
anakin skywalker hayden christensen
is returning that is nuts to me i didn't
think they would pull that off with him
no i mean this truly is crazier of like
crazy
back and like paying them their just do
or their homage or whatever and yeah i
mean
as a second chance for him in the live
action stage to really
come back in and captivate people that's
that's pretty exciting especially for
the flack he got back in the day and
they said it's going to be taking place
15 years after um
the the events of revenge of the sith i
don't know what he's gonna appear as
will be in flashbacks will he be
the guy underneath the darth vader
outfit you know i remember a time
in star wars rebels specifically the
ahsoka tano fight
with anakin skywalker when she does hit
his mask you know you do see like oh it
looks like anakin's face he doesn't look
like what he he looked like at return of
the jedi stage
so maybe we'll get something kind of
like that either way the fact that
hayden christensen's returning that for
some reason that's a piece of news i
just did not expect to hear
and they also mentioned a lando series
in development as well and i i don't
know if they
it has to be donald glover who's
returning to the role right
i didn't see anything about them
mentioning donald i just saw like the
image
pull up on screen i actually wasn't
listening at the time when they
announced it scrambling to make sure we
could
talk about some of the stuff it's making
me wonder will alden ehrenreich's
han solo appear in there i mean that'd
be pretty
i'm willing to give him a second shot
let's give it a shot
why not they're also doing like a droid
story they're doing this other thing
called the star wars visions
and original series of animated shorts
they're doing a whole bunch
of star wars here the future of star
wars is in
television well and that's what the
future did i mean
this marks a shift for them towards
direct to consumer uh based content so
they do have theatrical but it seems
like they're focusing on disney plus now
and then of course for the first time in
a long time star wars movies
announcements
you got patty jenkins who's gonna be she
put out some video on twitter i think he
might have played at the event but it's
definitely on twitter right now where
she's getting dressed we don't know what
she's getting dressed for she's getting
and then you find out this game the
rogue squadron gear she's doing fighter
pilot movie called rogue squadron i'm
excited to see what she does there man
that's pretty awesome and then of course
your homeboy
taiko ytd that's right it's official he
is directing he directed the season
finale of season one for the mandalorian
and that was his audition to direct
the new a new star wars feature film and
that's really cool man i mean like
we began all this tv news and there's a
gazillion tv things we're talking about
now taika ytd uh doing this and patty
jenkins acclaimed directors from both
the marvel and dc
world that's right all coming together
man
there's also this other one called the
acolyte which is a mystery thriller that
will take viewers into a galaxy of
shadowy secrets and emerging dark side
powers in the final days of the high
republic era
it looks like they're just exploring
all different timeline of
the star wars galaxy out of all these
announcements you know it's like of
course the nostalgia side of me is very
much looking forward to seeing
the obi-wan kenobi series i'm really
looking forward to the ahsoka tano show
especially after the way rebels ended
there's something about it it's very
very much drawn to the idea of patty
jenkins doing the rogue squadron movie
i'm not sure which one's the most kind
of you guys but there's something very
exciting to me about that one also star
wars i mean just to briefly touch on
visions apparently they're taking a dive
into anime specifically which is going
to be a super cool thing like
in a genre and a medium that has such
sci-fi and cyberpunk influence and
inspiration i can't wait to see star
wars transcribed there
they have this sizzle reel out for
cassie and andor which was at the point
we're like oh we gotta turn away now
this is something we gotta react to yeah
there's footage because
yeah look away footage footage you know
so uh yeah we're gonna watch that right
now with you guys
let's get into it
[Music]
the oldest fans
it was a bittersweet feeling you know in
the premiere
knowing that it was just one film
but then magic happens right
sexy as that is ever
something you like so much the enormity
of this is like doing a big feature film
it's very cinematic for me that's where
the excitement is 12 episodes
12 scripts over 200 names
[Music]
has the same care level of attention to
detail
suppression damn
it's brilliant it is the building
wow
i hope they do the credits like this
[Music]
that's gonna be really cool yeah that's
gonna be really cool
i hear my mothma's in it too and stone
skarsgard is gonna be in here too
yeah that'd be crazy because darcy is
gonna be uh
kat dennings is gonna be in one division
so i thought that perhaps stellen
skarsgard character might appear in one
of these
marvel shows so you know it could be a
case where he's in one of the marvel
shows two down the road and he's in one
of the star wars shows as well it seems
like disney just has a stable now that
yeah
between all the biggest franchises on
earth i mean this is
all really cool stuff i'm excited to see
what they're doing mandalorian season
two has been
awesome and then uh season three they
already hard at work at
i actually know someone who is directing
one of the episodes i think episode four
or five for
the next season i don't know if i'm
allowed to name drop who yet but
when it's official anyway guys we're
trying to keep up today with all these
things coming out
and uh yeah we'll talk to you guys soon
subscribe hit that notification bell
especially if a big trailer or something
comes out we want to make sure
we're going to cover it right away
thanks guys
david gandy i was just messaging you
back on patreon
and apparently you're in the er right
now or
you've been admitted there i'm sorry to
hear about what's happened
and why you're currently laying in a
hospital bed
i hope that while you're there you're
able to
use it as a time to figure out some more
of those housing issues you're dealing
with maybe watch some cool youtube
videos maybe catch up on our videos
that's probably the most important thing
you should be doing i
told you you shouldn't have taken too
many pills now he wasn't able to get it
to go down
i know that you're in a new place and
you want to you know meet new people and
stuff like that but you really
got to reign it in all right it's
cuffing season and all that but you know
you can't take that too
seriously all right but all seriousness
david i want you to have a good
christmas
you have been a jolly fellow in our
lives
and the last thing i want is for you to
be having some
serious things to worry about you're
closer to some family members now that
you're out in arizona
so my friend i hope you heal recover get
well as soon as possible
but while you're there watch all our
videos because we could use some ad
revenues
and give us those views to do